130 tage krieg in der ukraine und auch
heute wollen wir uns die militärische
lage ansehen putins invasionsarmee man
muss es so klar sagen ist ein riesiger
erfolg gelungen in diesem krieg erstmals
ist eine gesamte region eine gesamte
region des landes nämlich der region
luhansk im osten des landes unter
russische kontrolle geraten das ist
russlands armee bislang nicht passiert
die stadt und die umliegenden etwa fünf
bis sechs dörfer die dort noch unter
ukrainischer kontrolle standen sind in
den letzten jahr 24 bis 48 stunden ist
nicht ganz klar an russlands
invasionsarmee gefeiert und seitdem ist
sozusagen die erste die allererste
provinz des landes komplett unter
russische kontrolle und wir sehen hier
unten im süden dieses dunkel rote gebiet
das ist das gebiet was bereits 2014 von
dieser pseudo volksrepublik dogans
sozusagen beherrscht wurde die vom kreml
kontrolliert wurde und dieses gesamte
rote gebiet hier oben das wurde seit dem
24 februar erobert in lizenz selber
feiern die invasoren dort feiert die
invasionsarmee hier vor einem von einer
ballistischen rakete zerstörten
administrations gebäude von legends und
man feiert hier sein sieg und wir müssen
uns noch einmal diese diese fahren
angucken denn die sagen schon sehr sehr
viel aus über das was wir hier sehen das
sind also
invasoren verbrecher kriegsverbrecher
aller herren länder sie sich vereinigt
haben einmal hier aus der autonomen
republik tschetschenien die natürlichen
unter russischer kontrolle steht das ist
die tschetschenen flagge hier sehen wir
eine erinnerungs frage an die
sowjetunion also auch solche ideologen
sind dabei hier die flagge russland und
hier unten die flagge der sogenannten
volksrepublik nur ganz also dieser bunte
mix von jeweils von putin abhängigen und
von putin eben in die ukraine geschickt
ja invasoren hat hier die stadt erobert
und hat die ehemals 100.000
einwohnerstadt distanz nach ungefähr
zwei wochen kampf unter ihre kontrolle
gebracht was kann der ukraine noch
helfen hier überhaupt etwas zu schaffen
und überhaupt sich dem zu erwehren
dieser invasionsarmee nun es sind vor
allem die westlichen geschützte
natürlich die westliche artillerie und
wir haben jetzt neue bilder die zeigen
dass frankreich zu seiner cesar
artillerie ganz besondere munition
geliefert hat die auch besonders
gefährlich ist für hier die russische
aggression wir achten mal auf dieses
video unten ist ziel was gleich
angegriffen wird das können wir uns
erstmal ansehen da sehen wir die
explosion aber wir wollen uns das ganze
nochmal ansehen und was besonders ist
hier oben hier sehen wir gleich ein
blitz ein blitz im himmel da war er kurz
bevor wir unten die explosion haben und
das ganze nennt sich eine bonus munition
eine munition die aus etwa 30 kilometer
entfernten verschossen wurde von diese
materie geschützt aber eben und das ist
das besondere nicht direkt hier unten
einschlägt sondern hier oben explodiert
und eine gerichtete ladung in einen
bereich da unten feiert der eben das
ziel ist und insofern auch eine viel
größere durchschlagskraft hat weil eben
nicht nur an einem ort sondern in
ungefähr zehn mal zehn metern alles
zerstört wird was das dorf befindet
frankreich hat also offenbar hier extrem
hightech munition geliefert um die
russische invasion zumindest nach der
eroberung von lohans zu stoppen und wie
tödlich diese
artillerieangriff sind der ukraine so
wurden eigene artery als auch mit
westlicher dass hier noch mal zu sehen
hier haben wir ein hier haben wir einen
tee 80 panzer der hier getroffen wurde
und wir sehen außenrum die artillerie
einschläge überall die einschläge und
einige von denen haben offenbar den
panzer so schwer getroffen dass er jetzt
auch
sozusagen vor sich hin hier qualmt und
kurz danach dann auch explodiert und wir
sehen dass was wir so oft sehen bei die
putins panzern nämlich dass sie aufgrund
ihrer ladevorrichtung die kreis rund um
den turm aufgebaut ist dass der turm
hier in die richtung wegfliegt also wir
gucken uns das noch mal an hier der
explodierende panzer hier der turm der
dorthin fliegt haben wir das erst mal
laufen und wir sehen wie der ton dann zu
boden fällt und etwa 10 20 meter vom
panzer entfernt dort dort ja dann vor
sich vor sich hin brennt das ganze gilt
auch für die schützenpanzer hier ein bmp
einst auch der russischen invasionsarmee
was hier man nennt das kocht wo also die
munition schon so am köcheln ist aber
noch nicht ganz explodiert ist und kurz
darauf kommt es dann zu dem mega
explosion wie so oft und auch hier wir
gucken uns das mal an hier oben man muss
ganz in die ecke sich an das angucken
hier ist der geschützturm dieses
schützenpanzers mit der kanone die hier
nach vorne zeigt dass also wiederum
dieses phänomen wenn man so möchte dass
der geschützturm von hier bis da oben
fliegt auf grund dessen dass die gesamte
explosion
auf einmal in die luft fliegt das also
das große problem was ist schon öfter
besprochen haben von putins panzern und
schützenpanzern aber eben auch diese
aufnahmen zeigen dass die ukraine extrem
erfolgreich vorgeht wir haben am ende
noch mal ein video wo man sieht dass 77
panzer und schützenpanzer hier zerstört
wurden von einem russischen konvoi auch
hier sehen wir wieder die arterie
einschlagkrater und dann die
verschiedenen brennenden fahrzeuge da
ist 11 wir haben da einen sinn in der
ecke putins invasionsarmee zeit einen
unglaublichen blutzoll von etwa 100 bis
200 soldaten am tag die hier sterben in
der ukraine doch der kreml möchte diesen
feldzug fortführen und er hat heute mit
der eroberung von lohans keinen
wichtigen teilerfolg erzielt